Mom thank you so much for being here
today thank you for having me so tell me
how you became involved in the VC
industry
I actually started my first VC job with
Tim Draper based in in San Francisco he
has a network of VC funds and also kind
of a great mission to empower early
stage Founders so I met him at the very
very beginning of my career and at the
time I was actually involved in biotech
a lot more focusing on the science part
and he asked me to join his firm and I
ended up staying there for about four
years and a half before joining 500 so
that that's how it started excellent and
what companies what types of companies
are you looking to invest in right now
are you really excited about
well for one for sure you know Africa is
a great
um an exciting BC Market because of not
only the opportunity in different
sectors but also because uh we're seeing
now that BC as an asset class is
actually starting to pick up so
um you know I I think that in addition
of emerging markets in general Africa is
quite exciting we're sector agnostic so
we often look at companies from all
sectors we do invest in Tech driven
companies so they have to be at least
Tech driven in that in that regard but
when I look at the content today I think
there is a wide range of opportunities
in various sectors related to health
education
agriculture
biotech fintech obviously but also
Marketplace and supply chain so there's
just so much on top opportunities in so
many sectors that for me I think it
makes it even more exciting what is the
biggest mistake that you see Founders
make when they're trying to pitch you or
their company
a big one like I mentioned earlier is
the assumption that they don't have to
be proactive about setting the
foundations of their company to be able
to scale and and thinking that it will
come along the way
um because because of how fragmented the
market is they do need very early on to
be quite pragmatic and proactive about
what we mean to be active in multiple
markets so that's one and and the second
one is really they need to be able to
think about setting the foundation of
their companies to be attractive at the
later stage so when it comes to like I
said accounting bookkeeping even IP
contracts with employees just making
sure that they're setting best practices
from the beginning and and I think you
know it's on the assumption that they
will be able to change
when things get serious but I always say
it's much easier to start a habit than
to change it so
um trying to start with leading with
those best practices before trying to
change them later on right makes sense
and my last question for you is because
you know we're two women sitting here
it's no secret that women don't receive
as much VC funding as men
um how do you think this can can change
on the continent
so it's a it's a sad truth right when
you look at the numbers most of the
investment is going to mail driven
companies
um male-driven Founders and
um it's it's it's quite ironical because
when you look at entrepreneurs across
the continent especially even when you
look on the SME side the continent is
the place that has the highest number of
female entrepreneurs so a lot of the
African economies are actually driven by
female entrepreneurs and so the question
becomes if the economies are mainly
driven by female entrepreneurs why are
they not receiving nearly the same
amount of funding and I think a lot of
it comes from access
they don't have access to the same
opportunities but also they don't have
access to the same tools that allow them
to maybe be as polished as male Founders
are by the time they get in front of
investors so a lot of it really comes
through how do we get to female founders
from the beginning how do we make sure
that we give them the tools that allow
them to be just as equipped when it
comes to VC entrepreneurship but also I
think it also poses a question of how do
we look at different forms of financing
because the type of businesses that
female entrepreneurs are leading often
require different forms of financing
than Equity so whether it be debt or
loans or microfinance
um that usually is a lot of the type of
working capital that they need and
because those forms of financing are not
necessarily as developed the numbers are
are very very low compared to the number
of female entrepreneurs right
well thank you so much I really
appreciate you being here today thank
you thank you so much